Does your life have purpose, meaning, and
direction?
… Turns out, if you have a reason to live,
you just might live longer!
Hi Guys, Crystal here back for DNews.
It seems like we are alway seeing news articles
discussing the connection between mental and
physical health, but researchers at Mount
Sinai Hospital have recently announced that
a sense of purpose in our lives can actually
increase longevity.
The research team performed a meta analysis
-- so they didn’t collect their own data--
but they reviewed 10 studies containing information
from a total of more than 137,000 people.
They found that a strong sense of purpose
reduces deaths from all causes by 23 percent
and lowers the risk of heart attack by 19
percent.
Researchers defined “purpose” as a self
reported sense of “meaning, direction, and
a feeling that life is worth living.”
And that could mean different things to different
people - whether it’s spirituality, raising
a family, having a career you love, or creating
art.
A preventive cardiologist associated with
the study, is quoted as saying: "As part of
our overall health, each of us needs to ask
ourselves the critical question of 'do I have
a sense of purpose in my life?'
If not, you need to work toward the important
goal of obtaining one for your overall well-being."
So, that’s easy! if you want to live longer,
find a reason to.
Simple right?
Well … not really.
Besides the task of finding a life’s purpose
being a little more complicated than simply
deciding to be happy, the impact of mental
health on physical health has greater implications
than just individual experience and longevity.
According to the Center for Disease Control
(CDC), In 2010, the total costs of cardiovascular
diseases in the United States were estimated
to be over 400 billion dollars.
Approximately $1 of every $6 spent on health
care in this country is spent treating cardiovascular
conditions.
As the U.S. population ages, the economic
burden of cardiovascular diseases on our health-care
system will continue to grow.
A study performed at Harvard University followed
men and women aged 25 to 74 for 20 years,
found that a sense of enthusiasm, of hopefulness,
of engagement in life, and the ability to
face life’s stresses with emotional balance
reduced the risk of coronary heart disease.
And cardiovascular health isn’t the only
health concern impacted by a more fulfilled
life, similar results have been published
for diabetes, and stroke amongst other things.
Society pays an increasing cost for treatment
of these diseases, and it will be interesting
to see whether the ever increasing scientific
literature linking mental well-being to reduced
risk for chronic disease will result in a
shift in emphasis from treating resulting
conditions to preventative care.
So what gives you purpose in your life?
For one 13-year-old boy, it’s helping the
blind.
Our new sister channel Seeker has a video
about this inspiring teenager, who built a
braille printer out
of Legos:
So make sure you check that video out, it’s
the first link in the description, and subscribe
to Seeker so you never miss a video!